a question that entrepreneur ramaswamy
has spent a great deal of time thinking
about through two books as well as in
his latest Venture which he joins us
tonight to tell us about Vivek thanks so
much for coming on thank you so it does
seem like
Don Lemon you know just a cable host but
this is a perfect illustration of where
identity politics wind up
when you stray from Universal principles
that bind us all under the same rules
exactly I mean we are in the middle of
this national identity crisis Tucker
where we have celebrated our diversity
and our differences for so long that we
forgot all of the ways we're really just
the same as Americans Bound by a common
set of ideals that set this nation into
motion 250 years ago and that's what I'm
proud to say tonight that I'm running
for United States president to revive
those ideals in this country those basic
rules of the road meritocracy the idea
that you get ahead in this country not
on the color of your skin but in the
content of your character the idea that
you are allowed to speak freely yes to
be wrong sometimes as long as your
neighbor gets the same courtesy in
return the idea that the people who we
elect to run the government by the way
are the people who actually run the
government basic rules of the road these
are the things that bind us together you
and I have different shades of melon and
you know what I say so what that's not
beautiful that is not our strength our
diversity is meaningless if there's not
nothing greater that binds us together
across that diversity and the reason
that I'm running for president is to
revive those ideals and I believe deep
in my bones they still exist that most
Americans still believe in them but we
need to ReDiscover that and the only way
we can do it is by start to talking
openly start talking openly again so I'm
not going to ask you any political
questions because given my calls in the
midterms I don't understand American
politics I'm not going to ask you what
to do in eye or whatever other people
can do that
give us the bullet points of what you're
going to tell audiences as you Embark
from here on this campaign I think we
need to put Merit back into America in
every sphere of Our Lives I mean Merit
who in who gets into this country let's
start with that okay I think more people
like my parents can be a good thing for
this country but people whose First Act
of entering this country as a law
breaking one we should say a hard no to
that not just who gets in but also who
gets ahead decimating affirmative action
it has been a National Cancer one of my
top priorities will be to end
affirmative action in every sphere of
American Life and it's not just
meritocracy and who gets ahead ending an
affirmative action yes I mean our whole
government is based on that idea well
the funny thing Tucker is this would be
easy an easy thing for president to do
Lyndon Johnson issued an executive order
that requires anyone who does business
with the US government that covers over
20 percent of the U.S Workforce to adopt
race-based quota systems any Republican
president since Lyndon Johnson could
have taken a pen and crossed that out we
haven't done it yet I think that's the
kind of Courage we're going to need to
muster to go after these sacred cows
from woke religion in the form of
affirmative action to this new climate
religion which is completely shackling
the American economy and culture we need
to take the most sacred cows of these
alternative secular religions and I'm
sorry to say this take them to the
slaughterhouse because that's what what
it's going to take for this National
Revival where we stop apologizing for
what it means to be American at all for
putting America first but in order to
put America first we have to first
ReDiscover what America is and to me
those are these basic rules of the road
that set this nation into motion from
meritocracy to free speech to
self-governance over aristocracy people
who we elect actually make them run the
government rather than this cancerous
Federal bureaucracy that's going to be
the heart of my message and I'll tell
you this we don't have an option anymore
okay we Face these external threats like
the rise of China which I think has got
to be our top foreign policy threat that
we've got to respond to not pointless
Wars somewhere else
that's going to require some sacrifice
it's going to require a declaration of
independence from China complete
decoupling and that's not going to be
easy it's going to require some
inconvenience buying cheap stuff for
that many years you know what we got
addicted to it that's going to require
some sacrifice but I think we can make
those sacrifices if we know what we are
sacrificing for and that's what I want
to see the GOP do answer the question of
what it means to be an American today if
we give an answer to that question we
dilute this woke agenda in these secular
religions to irrelevance yes I've been
complaining about them for the last
three years yes there's a role for
identifying the problem but if we want
to deliver a solution we're going to
need to ReDiscover that national
identity that we all share and if we do
that I still think honest deep in my
bones that our best days not in some
cheesy politician kind of way but
actually truly I think our best days can
be ahead of us but it's going to take
that Revival to make it happen I hope
you'll come back often because you are
one of the one of the great talkers
we've ever had but very quickly you
identified China as the primary concern
of American foreign policy you don't
think it's the war in Eastern Europe
absolutely correct and
ironization okay we gotta wake up to the
fact that China is violating our
sovereignty and the reason if that had
been a Russian spy balloon we'd have
shot it down instantly and ratcheted up
sanctions why didn't we do that for
China the answer is simple we depend on
them for our modern way of life okay
this economic co-dependent relationship
has to end and the only other priority
I'd add is actually if you're going to
use the military for something use it to
decimate the cartels South of the Border
in a failed Narco State that's now
actually killing people on American soil
with fentanyl that's what a good use of
a military looks like is actually
protecting American soil and American
interests not pointless War somewhere
else and I think that the heart of this
goes to Reviving that national identity
what does it mean to be American then
you know what you need to defend and
that's where our domestic policy vision
and this cultural vision is inextricably
linked it's tied to our foreign policy
Vision too and that's why I'm running
for president because I think that needs
to be at the top of the gop's agenda I
think it needs to be at the top of this
country's agenda and I'm running for
president to make it happen that is so
far from the current agenda that will be
fascinating to see you weight into this
race and we appreciate your announcing
tonight here thank you Thomas for me
thank you very much subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube channel to catch our
nightly opens stories that are changing
the world and changing your life from
Tucker Carlson tonight